here's the first big story from newsweek
donald trump labeled a flight risk after
saying fbi took his passports newsweek
reports trump wrote in a post on his
truth social platform that the fbi stole
the passports one of which he said was
expired during the search on august 8th
this is an assault on a political
opponent at a level never seen before in
our country third world he wrote while
trump did not offer any details on why
the fbi may have wanted the passports
some twitter users suggested that it was
because the ex-president was viewed as a
flight risk
attorney seth abramson wrote in a
twitter thread on monday that if the
news was true the fbi is acknowledging
what i've long said is a quote which is
that as a factual matter trump is a
flight risk and i just got to point out
perhaps it was the giant 757 with
trump's name on it that made them
concerned trump might be able to leave
the country but i also want to add just
very very quickly as well
for
you guys you know
people like trump don't live the way we
live all right donald trump does not
need a passport
donald trump is a billionaire donald
trump makes a phone call actually donald
trump doesn't make a phone call when he
when he charters his flights his people
probably call the people of the country
he's going to and they don't need to
verify donald trump's identity and the
amount of money that he has and
investments in many of these countries
they're gonna roll out the red carpet
for him people don't realize this stuff
so i'm wondering why this happened and
of course there's some speculation maybe
that in the documents they grabbed they
didn't realize that a box had trump's
passports in it or something
but i'm just not giving the benefit out
to the fbi i think they took his
passports i think their only option now
is to lean into if you're going after
the king you can't miss and so earlier
today i said i didn't think that they
would indict them with the information
coming out now that they plan on
releasing more information about these
affidavits
i'm starting to lean the other direction
i think they might have no choice but
again man i really don't know i don't
know what do you guys think
it bothers me that the doj is like we
oppose releasing the affidavit after
they claim that they were going to
promote transparency i mean you can't
really have it both ways they're citing
national security concerns but again it
seems like everything is lined up they
just don't want to admit what they're
doing
and don't you have to be charged with
something before you become a flight
risk i mean they haven't really now
formally charged him with something i
mean look uh i'm not a lawyer i'm a
criminal lawyer but i have watched law
and order oh yeah
okay then the best legal action
give it to us no i'm pretty sure you can
be instructed not to leave uh during an
investigation but they didn't even do
that but they didn't do that that's what
i mean it's like there's i don't know
why how you can declare somebody a
flight risk if you haven't been charged
with anything
from yeah but i think he's just i mean
trump said he was declared a flight risk
right well no no people on social media
are saying this yeah and this is just so
it was nothing formal it's just the fact
that they are pre there oh they must
have taken it because they can't declare
him one officially they're just taking
away his ability to leave yeah they're
not really yeah donald trump can call
saudi arabian big listen i'm coming in
roll out the red cap and they're good
they're gonna do it like sure they're
gonna be bringing a very nice plane it's
one of the best planes
we'll get you on it i'll get you drinks
so so the question is
this is what's tough
the fbi didn't announce criminal charges
they're gonna be releasing more
information it's they're saying that
he's under a criminal investigation for
obstruction of justice and the espionage
act
so i would say
yeah the fbi can't declare him
or or maybe they can't
formally seize his passports so they
just sort of took him they accidentally
took them in the rain yeah oops can't
leave we had no idea they were in that
box that we specifically put them in
what is this obstruction of justice for
what i guess is this january 6th i don't
know
the espionage act is related to the
national archives well the withholding
of documents it might be the classified
document thing right that they say he
has all these classified documents which
he says he declassified which he could
declassify simply by saying it yeah just
by saying everything i watched a video
earlier with
uh comey talking with hillary clinton
just superimposed juxtaposed to each
other where he's saying we you know in
her emails we found 30 plus
110 110 classified pieces of information
in her gmail account i think it was all
in her gmail account saying it shouldn't
have been in a gmail account it wasn't a
private sector
you know private hillary clinton server
had 110 classified documents
out of 30 000 public records that she
did not have the legal authority to
destroy keep that up keep that in mind
that she had classified documents in her
personal server so let's just keep that
in mind i want to keep that in mind when
we're looking at talking about trump and
she's not a president she was secretary
of state which does not have uh
unilateral declassification powers
so here's what i try to explain to
people imagine you're the president
and you're going to negotiate with
gorbachev about nuclear armaments
and you sit down and and you say look we
know you got missiles in turkey and you
gotta move those
and then he goes okay well then what
about your missiles that you have placed
in you know around us oh i can't talk
about that they're classified sorry i
have no idea
that's insane of course the president
can decide to tell an enemy about our
weapons he's the commander-in-chief he
has to be able to negotiate that it
would be it would be insane to us and be
like let me get back to you and see if i
can get the bureaucrats to determine if
i the president have the authority to
negotiate armaments that's what would be
happening with biden right now i don't
think that's the thing
yeah that's what you can't let biden
make ryden probably doesn't know
anything about the nuclear codes but
that's because they can't you know trust
him and they're not willing to admit
that where i think you're totally right
there's no way for trump to have been as
an effective leader as he could as he
was without anything to negotiate with
it doesn't make any sense but all
presidents
every single one of them now again
i'm seeing these memes go around where
it's you know it's like there's one meme
of like a little girl and she's got like
a shocked look on her face and it's like
if you chanted lock her up over
hillary's emails and now you are
defending trump let's just admit it was
never really about the emails and then i
just i'm like i'm gonna i'm gonna
respond on facebook because i waste time
trolling sometimes or i should say
trolling and i just responded with very
matter of fact sorted politifact uh
several sources said hillary clinton had
110
confidential amazon a private server and
they politely investigated and then said
there was no intent have a nice day even
though she's she was secretary of state
with no declassification power donald
trump
after kevin kleinsmith was sentenced to
probation for fabricating evidence to
justify spying on the president you
can't expect me to believe that trump
has done something wrong no the the the
benefit of the doubt is gone and you
need to prove you had a legitimate
reason to do this
but still donald trump as the president
has broad declassification powers so i
just don't see anything here not to
mention the the warrant for the search
of trump's home said from the first day
of his presidency the last davis
presidency how is that constitutional
the fourth amendment if it prohibits
you know unreasonable search and seizure
you need to be able to be like we
believe you have this document that says
this thing and we're going to prove it
instead they're just like i'll take it
all
every single thing you got
yes and then an epstein judge signed off
on it how about that i'm sorry a judge
who had been a lawyer defending right
epstein's lieutenants i want to make
sure i'm being clear on that one because
it's actually worse than saying it's so
much worse
i don't know i've seen had lieutenants
who are they
yeah
my friend larry correa who's a author he
said if i'd put that in a book that the
judge who signed this affidavit
worked for epstein people who said oh
come on let's see editors are rejected
be like it's a little too much
well there are so many outlets that are
like we're just going to skip reporting
that we don't want to mention it because
it starts to sound as sketchy as it
really is yeah that's a really crazy
story right it's all you know there's a
a bunch of viral me
viva fry i think posted this
it's a it's a mo it's a montage yeah is
it a music
it's a montage of pictures all of these
verified individuals saying
that they've gotten coveted and they're
so grateful to be vaccinated protected
now i'm not going to comment on the
covet nonsense the cdc put out
guidelines saying that their policies
now for the unvaccinated vaccine are the
same or whatever i'm not here to comment
on that i'm here to comment on the
identical posting of all of these people
around the world makes me feel like
there's like one guy behind all the
accounts is copying and pasting
everything and then i saw that and i was
like
when you when you you guys ever see that
video that dead spin put together where
all of the news anchors are saying the
exact same yeah yeah it just feels like
that it's like it's it it really just
feels like there's a machine like it's
all fake these people aren't real people
they're not saying real things they're
not having real thoughts and there are
world leaders who are of that and there
are news anchors who are of that and
that's freaky
there it is a machine and people are
being fed a narrative but the the crazy
part is it's not fake it's real they're
real people they're just allowing
themselves to be changed by their
superiors it reminds me of the phrase
party line like when i'm researching
stories to write for the site you know
you'll see that ap news put out a story
ap news does that a lot and then it gets
picked up in 87 different places and
there's no other original reporting into
this so you just have the party line
repeated over and over again the same
statistics the same quotes the same
perspective but because it's multiple
outlets they're acting like oh yes we're
all reporting this very important story
that actually only one of us wrote it's
why the theory that there's like one guy
putting out the same post for every
country like it doesn't seem that crazy
to me because they just copy what their
the other people are doing dead internet
theory you guys you guys know about that
you know about that nick dead internet
theory the idea is that sometime around
2016 the internet basically became fake
like almost all of the posts are made by
ai and bots to manipulate public opinion
and the average person doesn't really
engage anymore
and uh
i don't know if i would believe that but
i would believe that mass censorship was
enacted on such a scale that the average
person has no voice and only a small
percentage of approved people are
actually posting and that's
that's pretty much reality yeah well i'm
so shadow band i mean you know i my
posts don't get very much penetration
ever on twitter right
i think
we see it a lot that uh when it comes
censorship high profile people get
censored periodically but it's always
the smaller accounts who get hit
instantly without notice and without
reason it doesn't make sense and i hear
this from people when i go out and talk
you know i'll meet some regular guy like
i had 100 followers and they banned me
because i posted a news story
and who are you going to tell what are
you going to do about it right so that
kind of makes me feel like
you know if we go back to when elon musk
was trying to buy twitter and now he
apparently doesn't want to buy it when
that weird shift happened and overnight
people associated with like libertarian
conservative or independent all saw a
massive massive gain and subscribers on
the left saw message drop off
really does make you think the dead
internet theory might be real and we're
just arguing with bots 24 7.
the internet was what darpa tech arpa
arpa it was uh military technology
basically it was i think it's it was
created as a weapon basically or is like
it's gonna get created so let's create
it first and it was like the internet
yeah
and now that's being used like i mean i
was watching jimmy you know bright
insight he does uh research on i don't
know his last name is but jimmy is his
first name his youtube channel is bright
inside talking about search results
coming back and like he was searched
like january 6 and then you'd say 800 or
8 billion search results here you go and
every page you'd go to would be showing
them the same results it would be
wikipedia at the top a certain january 6
page they want you to see then you go to
like next page
wikipedia at the top the same article
again on the next page next page same
thing
this is google and then he tried a
different search engine i think he used
like duckduckgo and he was getting the
same problem so i think it's becoming
very clear that the the military is
using it if it's not the the military i
don't know who but someone is using the
internet right now as a tool well yeah
greater than the masses that are also
using it as a tool it could be it could
be emergent in that special interest in
corporations you know for one reason or
another are pushing in this direction
you can say it's political you can say
it's criminal you can say it's it's it's
capitalistic or whatever but there's an
incentive for googling these companies
to do what they do thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there